don't we all take too many pictures of
ourselves but you know what to be able
to pop this t-shirt on and post a
picture with the hashtag watch on your
stops and first off of course you're
telling people you know about this
problem getting them engaged okay
we're also donating in this instance
every time you post something we're
donating 50 meals everyone could do it
yeah and you've got some really strong
wonderful women I mean Kate Hudson
behind this campaign
how did sort of that that collaboration
happen sometimes I think that in
Hollywood and in fashion you know there
there's a lot of you know Oh seriousness
and very morose and very intense and and
I'm the believer that in fact you know
optimism and upbeat energy combined with
smarts and talent that's the best thing
possible and you know I've known Kate
for a long time and and she's got all of
that and it's very much how I operate
and I knew she'd be so great
to be someone we could partner with in
getting the message out there and she's
she's been remarkable where did it all
begin for you do you remember the moment
whether you're a little kid
and you were looking at something maybe
your mother was wearing or is was there
a moment for you that really turned
everything on I grew up in a family of
fashionistas my mom model my grandfather
was in the textile business I had an
uncle who was a manufacturer and aunts
and grandmother and everyone just
obsessed with clothes so I did grow up
you know really young listening to
people talk about fashion and then my
mom got remarried when I was five and
she had ordered a very extravagant
wedding dress she put the dress on and I
sat in the corner kind of Grenaa Singh
and my mom looked at me and said what's
wrong and the dress was covered with all
these bows
okay and I said those bows they're
terrible and my mom asked the tailor to
stop him and they started clipping the
bows off and it looked better but from
that point on I you know I sketched and
and for me you know in Breakfast at
Tiffany's Holly Golightly says nothing
bad could happen you know when you're in
Tiffany's I felt that way shop you know
just in general I'd walk into a store
and I loved it when I interview people
in the red carpet often times they'll
say who are you wearing and I get a lot
of Michael Kors where did those
relationships start for you because you
are have dressed some of the most
beautiful women Blake Lively Michelle
Obama and there's so many fantastic
people well I have to say I was very
lucky before I started my own business
when I was in my late teens early 20s I
designed for a boutique here in New York
we were just in the right place at the
right time so everyone from Goldie Hawn
to Diana Ross to Jackie Kennedy and they
were all clients and you know to me my
my favorite thing when I hear a
celebrity tell me after they've gone to
an event and I'll say oh he looked
amazing you know shoot them a text and
you look great and they say I loved how
I looked but I actually was comfortable
there was well especially on the red
carpet you know I mean it's a very
taxing moment for a lot of celebrities
so then I know I've done my job well is
there anyone that you haven't dressed
that you would like to get your hands on
I know this sounds nuts no but you know
how I'd love to dress Queen Elizabeth oh
my god I think she is the ultimate that
would be amazing
know she's not a bad idea I mean but I
think she really understands herself
well you know I mean think about the
idea of consistency knowing your body
knowing your position she does she knows
all of that
and I and and I have to take my hat off
to her